es ist sowieso schwierig dar über das
thema zu reden wenn man solche
schlagzeilen seht aber sie denken es
geht um afghanistan nein die für
versagen ist eigentlich schon seit
jahrhunderten immer wieder zu beobachten
ob das mit fünf pico und die teilung
diese nahen osten in nationalstaaten was
gar nicht funktioniert ob das die
politik in syrien ob das der gaza wahl
ob das im iran ob das emirat und jetzt
in afghanistan das abendland hat das
morgenland nicht verstand und wir haben
die religion die mentalität die kultur
die menschen nicht verstanden man kann
nicht mit bank sah man kann nicht mit
kampfflugzeugen demokratie exportieren
man muss anders arbeiten das war doch zu
sehen dass der taliban da ein tag danach
ein golfer nie weg er war immer da in
den köpfen der menschen und jetzt reden
wir über moderate taliban da sehen wir
was da passiert und was noch passieren
wird diese weg ist nicht nur in
afghanistan zu spüren diese sieg wird
ganz ganz viele terrororganisationen
weltweit eine motivation geben wir haben
den usa wir haben den westen besiegt und
jetzt werden sie noch motivation haben
terroranschläge in afghanistan im nahen
osten in syrien aber auch in europa zu
betreiben wir haben nicht nur die leute
nicht geholfen die auf der seite des
westens standen und wie im stich
gelassen sondern wir haben diese
regionen der welt nicht verstanden und
werden das nicht verstehen wenn wir
nichts sagen werden die für kultur diese
religion verständnis bringt unheil über
diese länder wenn man was ändern will
dann muss man demokratische
grundstrukturen aufbauen dann muss man
partner suchen die liberal sind dann
muss man nicht mit den taliban
verhandeln oder mit den hamas sondern
parallel strukturen schaffen man muss
das bildungssystem anders machen man
muss mündiger bürger schaffen genau wie
usa hier in europa und vor allem hier in
deutschland nachdem welt zweiten
weltkrieg gemacht hat das was der westen
macht da ist er falsch beraten und das
würden noch viele dieser frauen
nicht verstanden herr ist
also die amerikaner haben sie in ihrer
ganzen geschichte nicht verstanden sie
haben immer ihre schlimmsten feinde
bewaffnet die sie hinterher mit den
amerikanischen waffen bekämpft haben das
ist in afghanistan wieder so die haben
beispielsweise den taliban stinger
raketen geliefert mit denen man
flugzeuge abschießen kann um die sowjets
zu bekämpfen die damals im land waren
und damit sind dann später amerikanische
hubschrauber abgeschossen die amerikaner
haben aus dieser leidvollen geschichte
nie was gelernt sie machen immer wieder
die selben fehler und europa reden wir
nicht von europa sondern von deutschland
in deutschland ist es immer noch üblich
dass wir sagen dass wir uns an die
amerikaner ketten und sagen was die
machen ist richtig da machen wir mit das
ist verkehrt europa muss anfangen sich
eigenständig zu bewegen sich eigene
gedanken zu machen eine eigene
außenpolitik zu entwickeln und
deutschland muss das auch aber da sehe
ich nun in der nächsten zeit keine
besondere hoffnung muss ich sagen im
gegenteil die folge auch aber in zürich
dazu brauchen werden außenminister
heraus und brauchen wir dann auch die
minister hatten wir seit jahren keiner
da zufolge erfolgt dieser die folge
dieser toten wird sein dass jetzt hier
die flüchtlinge aus afghanistan mit
misstrauen empfangen werden die kommen
dass afghanistan wo ich weiß sie wie am
ende wie viele amerikanische soldaten
umgebracht worden sind und die debatte
wird wieder losgehen wie viele
terroristen sind darunter sind das
eigentlich wirklich unsere leute oder
sind die nicht mehr gefahr und das ist
ja auch das ziel der geschichte die
ganze rettungs und fluchtreaktion wird
dadurch vergeben die ein land ganz kurz
von dir fragen
mit jedem mit dem ich darüber spreche
der jetzt ich sag mal die überschriften
ist aber jetzt nicht so tief in diesem
detail drin ist er sagt ja jetzt schon
jetzt kommt das alles wieder jetzt
kommen die wieder auf uns zu und ich
glaube auch dass dieser vergleich von 1
laschet gleich 2015 zu lernen das auch
noch mal verstärkt hat ja also man merkt
dass in seinem eigenen umfeld die leute
haben angst davor unabhängig davon was
dort passiert ist und wer die
verantwortung trägt das auf uns jetzt
einfacher chaos und einwanderung zukommt
ungeordnet symbolen merkt genau das ist
eine debatte wird aber dass wir taliban
sympathisanten auch unter afghanen haben
ist keine frage dass merkel schon meine
arbeit in workshops immer wieder will
ich nicht homogen es gibt großartige auf
ghana unter uns die seit 2005 10 vorher
und nachher auch gekommen die demokraten
geworden sind die für die freiheit hier
sind die schätzen dass sie in
deutschland üblich aber es gibt eine
kleine minderheit von menschen die
taliban sympathisanten dass mir aber
große sorgen macht ist nicht diese
beiden oder 23 menschen die man die ihm
immer in jeder gruppe trifft sondern was
das eigentlich vor bedeutung hat wenn
terrororganisationen sehen man kann mit
1 terrororganisationen wie taliban mit
bar dutzend 1000 schlecht ausgebildete
terroristen ein weltmacht bewegen und
das haben sie ja die der mann so die
bundesregierung ist ja nun in einer und
andere westliche staaten nach einer
dramatischen kniffligen situation also
es gibt noch ortskräfte
die für die bundeswehr beispielsweise
gearbeitet haben die noch in afghanistan
sind die man jetzt versucht irgendwie
raus zu holen ist muss man also mit den
taliban verhandelt kann man eigentlich
mit den taliban aus ihrer sicht ja ja so
dass allein schon durch das taliban ist
ein terror organisationen jeder cent den
wir jetzt diese terroristen geben wird
gegen uns verwendet werden wir werden
dann leicht wir einkaufen ja frei drauf
aber wir kaufen 100 leute 209.000 und
die man wenig gearbeitet haben die frage
muss laufen warum was sie auch taten
warum haben wir so spät angefangen laut
kurier und das kind im brunnen die frage
ist ja wie wie schafft man es auch wenn
das kind im brunnen gefallen ist
zumindest zur hälfte eine nicht nur nach
hinten zu schauen und aufzuarbeiten was
war das eine aber die frage wie geht man
jetzt auch mit afghanistan falls also
jedenfalls fraktion jedenfalls nicht so
naiv wie die deutsche regierung schon
wieder naiv unterwegs ist also jetzt
lief gestern die nachricht rum ein
verhandler der deutschen bundesregierung
mit den taliban hat mitgeteilt die seien
bereit menschen ausreisen zu lassen
weiter ja die bedingungen die der gesagt
hat wurde dann schon in den nachrichten
zunehmend unterschlagen erklärlich
afghanen mit gültigen reisepapiere die
gültige reisepapiere stellen natürlich
die taliban aus das heißt ausreichend
darf der den wir ausreisen lassen wenn
einen draußen lassen weil eine papieren
und schon wird über die deutschen hoffen
aber dass wir auch bleiben
wir nehmen uns doch wahrscheinlich
trotzdem einig dass man grundsätzlich
jetzt unabhängig von zahlungen
miteinander im gespräch bleiben muss ich
finde es eher blamabel dass heiko maas
sagt wir deutsch die bundesregierung
deutschland hat keinen kontakt zu
taliban im land aber hat er mit vielen
terrorist aber nicht an dem sie die
terroristen handeln nicht fahren aber
wir müssen da mit denen er zumindest
sprechen oder nicht wir können sagen
auslandschweizer geben nein diese
menschen verstehen waren kastrati und
kanada zu gehen wenn man so macht ist
genau die entscheidende frage und da
sind sie auch glaube ich ein echter
experte terroristen verstehen nicht das
gespräch die verstehen möglicherweise
nur den gegendruck nur die geweihe
bedeutet das bedeutet aber dass die
glaube eine kernfrage wie künftig
umgehen deutschland muss nun was sich
aufrüsten manchmal werden terroristen
sogar zu staatsmännern ja guckt mal was
für aus aus
japan klar dass
das doch vor einer herz anzuschließen im
land darf mit ihnen nicht naiv vorhanden
muss so silber bedingung
machen
heute haben mit nach hause können
weitergefahren
vielleicht wollen wir auch alle gleich
noch beim kleinflächen auch sie zu hause
noch debattieren oder was sie auch sehr
gerne tun können was wir wahrscheinlich
auch jetzt tun werden ist die
sondersendung zuschauer und jetzt läuft
über mittlerweile elf us marines die
leider am flughafen kabul gestorben sind